يتجدد الحديث عن اعمار اوكرانيا بعد تسعه
اشهر من الحرب تتهم روسيا خلال تلك الفتره
بعدم تحقيق شيء سوى استهداف المدنيين
ومرافقهم الحيويه وخاصه خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه التي تكرر فيها قصف محطات كهرباء
وبنا تحتيه تتعاظم الحاجه لسلامتها مع بدا
الشتاء وفقا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطونيو بلانكن دمرت روسيا الثلث البنيه
التحتيه في اوكرانيا وتشمل القطاعات
المدمره شبكات المياه والصرف الصحي
والكهرباء بحسب تصريحات سابقه لرئيس
مجموعه البنك الدولي ديفيد معلباس كم تبلغ
كلفه اعاده الاعمار في اوكرانيا تزامنا مع
تصريحات لينكن تحدثت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسولافندر لاين عندما يقدر ب
600 مليار يورو مطالبه روسيا بتحمل
فاتورته
فظيعه بما في ذلك جرائمها ضد دوله ذات
سياده وعلى روسيا كذلك دفع تعويضات ماديه
جراء الدمار الذي تسببت فيه
الطريق الى ذلك وفق الاتحاد الاوروبي ياتي
عبر توظيف الاموال الروسيه المجمده في
عمليات اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا وهي ليست
المره الاولى التي يطالب فيها الاتحاد
الاوروبي بذلك موسكو من جهتها توعدت
باتخاد ما وصفتها باجراءات مناسبه اذا
تعلق الامر بمصادره اصولها في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفقا لتقديرات اوروبيه يبلغ
اجمالي الاصول الروسيه الخاصه المجمده في
الاتحاد ضمن العقوبات حوالي 19 مليار يورو
لا يمكن قانونيا مصادره تلك الاموال
المجمده الا في حال وجود ادانه جنائيه لعل
هذا ما يفسر تاكيد رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه على ضروره انشاء محكمه خاصه
مدعومه الامميه للتحقيق وملاحقه روسيا لكن
هذا المسار المقترح لم يسمح بالتصرف في
اموال روسيا المجمده قبل سنوات من التقاضي
البحث عن تصوير قانوني للتصرف في الاموال
الروسيه المجمده يشغل الاوروبيين منذ
الشهور الاولى للحرب لعله الفزع من تحميل
الاقتصاد الاوروبي المثقل اعباء اضافيه في
سبتمبر الماضي اكد تقرير اوروبي اوكراني
مشترك ان مئه وخمسه مليارات دولار مطلوبه
على مدار السنوات الثلاث القادمه لتلبيه
الاحتياجات العاجله وقدر حينها رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني كلفه المرحله الاولى من
اعاده الاعمار بنحو 17 مليار دولار يجب
توفير اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات منها هذا
العام وكان وزير الماليه الاوكراني قد اكد
قبل اشهر حاجه بلاده الى خمسه مليارات
دولار شهريا لضمان استمرار دوران عجلتها
الاقتص يا وسط الحرب فماذا تفعل اوروبا
اذاعه تلك الارقام لاحلى سوى البحث عن
مقترحات تشريعيه تسوغ توظيف المال الروسي
المجمد او ما سماه مسؤولون اوروبيون من
قبل كنز بوتين لجهه اعمار ما دمرته قواته
في اوكرانيا في هذا السياق يمتد النظر
الاوروبي ايضا الى حوالي 300 مليار يورو
من اصول البنك المركزي الروسي المجمده لكن
الحواجز القانونيه دونها اعقد بحكم كونها
مشموله بحصانه الدوله الروسيه حتى وان
عجزت موسكو عن التصرف فيها حاليا بسبب
العقوبات يبدو الطريق نحو اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا محفوظا بالجدل والصعوبات التي قد
تقلص من حجمه وعود التضامن الاوروبيه